♪ ♪
We're here
at a beautiful golf course
where I am golfing with an
incredible Chinese diplomat.
And we're gonna make
such a big deal today.
Hi, how are you?
Donald Trump.
Nice to meet you.
There you go.
Hi, how are you?
-We shake close
-Okay.
-in the United States. -Yeah,
let me pull you back, there.
-Hello, I'm the vice president,
Mike Pence. -Hello.
-I can't shake your hand.
I'm not... -No.
Mike can't touch women.
That's one of his weird
-Jesus rules.
-Yeah.
-Okay. -What's this guy's
name, anyway, huh?
Lee Tianming.
I'll call you Timmy.
Perfect, Timmy.
So, are you Timmy's caddy?
I'm his translator.
Oh. Well, great.
All right, Mike,
you're taking both the bags.
Timmy, you're with me.
Get in there. Get in...
Sit down.
♪ ♪
You speak any English?
We're gonna nuke you guys.
Okay, good.
Good, sir.
Yeah, nice, nice job.
-Nice job.
-He says good job.
If he plays golf like that,
imagine how
he's gonna negotiate.
♪ ♪
Look at that,
right on the green.
That's a shot.
So, anyway, The Purge--
so incredible.
One night a year,
they get to kill
anybody they want.
-(speaking Chinese)
-I don't know.
There's other movies I like.
I love Jackie Chan.
I don't know if you've been
watching Feud on FX.
Great story
about two elderly women
arguing with each other,
and they get to put to death
at the end,
which is my favorite part.
-(speaking Chinese) -He wants...
he wants to discuss,
uh, Ch-Chinese-American trade,
and not movies.
We're gonna get to that,
we're gonna get to that,
but The Purge-- so much fun.
♪ ♪
I cry at night all the time.
And I c...
It's uncontrollable.
Are you sure
you're negotiating properly?
We'll get to the negotiation.
-Trump! Trump! Trump! Trump!
-There we go, that's right.
-There we go. This guy right
here. -What's up? There you go.
-This guy right here.
-How you doing
-Hey, the best president ever.
-This guy...
Now, what are we gonna do?
Who are we gonna bomb first?
-I think we should bomb...
-Everybody. -(man shouting)
-...the Middle East.
-The whole thing?
-The whole (bleep) thing.
-Whole thing?
And use their asses as lighting
for-for the... for the airplane.
We could use their lit-up asses,
and they'd guide
all the planes in.
Don't you think that?
Then we drop
the mother of all bombs
on North Korea.
-MAN: Oh, yeah.
-TRUMP: It's so fantastic.
-Thank you, thank you.
-We're gonna destroy everybody.
We're gonna kill everybody.
Don't worry,
we're gonna kill everyone.
We'll kill everyone's families.
♪ ♪
Wow, I got it on.
Yeah, stiffen, stiffen, stiffen.
Tell him to stiffen.
-Don't-don't shake him
like that. -Stiffen.
Do you want some juice?
No, sir...
That's never how you do it.
That's never
the right way to do it.
You always... No, you always
have to put your mouth on it,
and then you suck in.
You shoot yours.
You smell nice.
Oh, my God.
That was awful.
Mike, get the ball.
(diplomat speaks Chinese)
He said he would love to talk
about deals with you.
Yeah, we're gonna... We're
totally gonna talk about deals.
It's gonna be great.
Look at the geese.
TRUMP:
It all comes down to this:
the Chinese diplomat and I
have spent a rigorous 18 holes
negotiating Chinese-American
trade relations,
and we've made
an incredible bet.
If I sink this putt,
then I get everything I want.
And if we don't,
the Chinese go home,
and I'm left empty-handed.
But I think I've got
this one in the bag.
Ready?
Get ready to pay up.
♪ ♪
Missed it.
Nice doing business with you.
Don't do it, Mike.
Don't talk to me.
Excuse me!
Excuse me.
We finished the deal.
Totally and completely in
the favor of the United States.
Please, you can't leave.
Tell him he can't leave.
I need a deal.
The Chinese diplomat melted
like butter in the sun.
I mean,
this guy was on his knees.
Please, God! Please, please!
I'll do whatever you want.
Every Chinese dissident
you lock up, I don't care.
Have another Tiananmen Square!
You could have
another Tiananmen Square!
I drove him so hard, by the end,
we got everything we wanted
and more.
I got money. I got money on me.
I think I have money on...
I don't have any money on me.
I do, I think.
I'll (bleep) your (bleep).
(bleep)
I've got a tongue like a little
turtle that's stuck in a pond,
and it won't come
all the way out.
And women say they love that.
(crying):
I just wanted to make a deal.
You did great.
America's great again.
America is totally great again.